thank you your majesty for what being
such a cool dude hey everybody I'm sure
you're screaming about that ending to
the Walking Dead episode so we'll break
everything down they did a bunch of
comic book Easter eggs and I'll try to
explain why they probably did that
ending this soon because it's relatively
early in the run this season but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing Walking Dead all season if
there's new giveaway stuff happening at
the end of the video - so largely it was
a carol ezekiel episode so probably the
best episode of the season so far
largely because those are two of the
best characters on the show in the show
now trades on a lot of character moments
like big Ezekiel speeches and that only
works when you have a really awesome
character like Ezekiel but top 10 WTF
comic book Easter eggs here we go number
10 the Ezekiel intro which is a totally
mundane look at the regular life he
leads as he's putting his costume on to
become the king like fake it till you
make it so this was a look at him
getting ready for a matinee performance
he narrated his backstory to Carol when
we got one of those flashbacks and he
just talks about how he used to take
care of Shiva as the zookeeper but he
also did those matinee performances this
is like him putting his makeup and his
costume on getting ready to perform for
a big crowd of people obviously it's his
people but it's still a performance fake
it till you make it
but number nine I love the way they
opened it with that we are one scene and
then they immediately cut to him
crawling out from the pile of bodies
like John snowed during Game of Thrones
they better thank Kit Harington for that
shot when he accepts his Emmy for his
performance in this week's episode like
after season six any time a character
crawls out from a giant pile of bodies
all I can think about is Jon Snow now
but it was so great just watching him
try to crawl away like he's in this
moment of horror he screams in agony
right after doing that big long speech
so the editing can sometimes get a
little bit weird with the way they jump
around in time but like I said because
the characters they're using in this
episode are so good it totally works so
I love the way they edited that intro
number eight though was ninja Carol I'm
so happy that she's back I hated
caryl so much last season I'm not gonna
fight I'm gonna hide in the cabin off by
myself she's back in it now she
infiltrates them and isn't it so nice
that they all line up for her so that
she can take them down with a couple
bullets remember that scene from the
beginning of Avengers age of Ultron
where Captain America puts his shield up
Thor bashes it and they take down all
those troops lining up well they're
excited number seven was that cinematic
Jerry save so one it was a really badass
Jerry moment but the way they shot it
was also really awesome too you just see
the camera as the body splits in half of
that douchebag Savior the flipside of
that is I was actually wondering if they
were gonna just have Ezekiel try to
stall him so that the Horde would
overtake them and he would waste all his
bullets and then his ego could take him
down but it all just feeds into
Ezekiel's Ark like him hitting rock
bottom and then getting that big
call-to-action again although
technically by the end of the episode it
seems like he's hit rock bottom again
but number six that Ezekiel Carol
flashback where they both narrate their
backstories a little bit and if you
haven't thought about them in a while
they actually have relatively similar
origin stories where they both had to
choose to be the hero when given the
choice Carol had to choose to be a
badass because her husband ed was this
abusive person she was a totally
different character at the beginning of
season 1 so through circumstance through
choice they became the badasses that
they are today although Ezekiel is sort
of saying I'm ready for this so he's not
quite the badass that Carol is but I'm
relatively optimistic about his
character so like he says he's ready and
is pretty clear that he's not ready
because he goes so crazy during the
episode but I think this is all meant to
catalyze him and we will see keying
Ezekiel again albeit just a slightly
different version just because the
events of this episode shook him so much
and how about all those visual metaphors
of the kingdom people following him
without question they're inspired by him
and then continuing to follow him
literally as walkers in death I love the
way the Savior through that in his face
it was a great metaphor because they're
in the frame the whole time is they're
limping away you can see how much it
tears Ezekiel up because one he wants to
get away from them their walkers they're
going to try and kill him
he also mourns them because just moments
ago they were some of his best friends
but number 5 jerry and ezekiel versus
the kingdom walkers so jerry has been a
total badass in this episode but it is a
good call to action for Ezekiel I think
he's ready to die in this moment he's
like this is the end
I'm totally gonna die he had that a
couple times during the episode just
leave me here I'm done so at every turn
he tries to get the people to leave him
behind so I think he's actually kind of
sad when he survives at the end of the
episode but number 4 Carol let's the
Savior's go so that she can save Ezekiel
so immediately in the episode I was like
okay this is gonna have crazy
consequences it'll weigh on Carol's soul
but the turn was so great when you hear
that Rev from the motorcycle and she
gives off that wry smile no they're not
gonna get the guns in that you know cut
to number three that big epic chase
scene probably one of the best scenes
from the episode aside from the intro
and what happened to Shiva at the end so
for as much as people complained about
the big action scene against the
Savior's in the first episode this is a
scene that the Walking Dead does really
well there aren't that many characters
there aren't that many things to deal
with she's a big stretch of abandoned
road the way they shot it was great
there was epic suspense the way you
think the Daryl's taken out of it but
then the camera pans out and you see him
come from behind Rick's car then the
funny Indiana Jones Last Crusade turn at
the end of the episode because you're
like oh my god Rick went down with a car
is he alive and you know just like
Indiana Jones he comes climbing off from
the side and they both look down you
look like [ __ ] dude so I feel like when
The Walking Dead is doing a really good
job operating on all cylinders they give
you that WTF moment where you're like oh
my god is the person that we really care
about dead and then they take it back in
some funny way so this was just their
indiana jones trick that they pulled on
you but number two was actually Ezekiel
returning at the end of the episode just
really sad that he's still alive and
everyone else is dead like you see all
their looks on their faces like they
understand instantly that all their
loved ones the fathers the husbands they
didn't come back because they're dead
and of course number 1 was the death of
Shiva so I know everybody on Twitter and
my feed was just going crazy when this
happened why are they doing this what's
going on well one it was actually
straight out of
the comics this is the way that Shiva
died when she was saving Ezekiel after a
failed attempt to take one of the
Savior's bases so obviously that was the
plot of this episode so they were giving
her the comic book death so if you're
wondering why they killed her this early
in the season it's because they did this
episode they did the failed attack this
early in the season if they would have
done it later than she would have died
later but just like in the comics she
dies
saving him and there's this big metaphor
with Shiva's blood like he was talking
about the back story when he jumped into
her pen when he was still a zookeeper
he saw her blood and jumped to action he
saw her blood in the sewer and we just
got to say that the sewer walkers are
just a special kind of gross in there's
this actual weird thing that they linger
on these hazardous material barrels a
lot of people were wondering about this
because this is relatively close to the
location where they found the really
melty looking Walker what happened to
this one and a bunch of people thought
that it might be a tip-off for the
whispers who cut patches of skin off of
dead Walker's to make Walker camo for
themselves but now because they're
spending so much time hyping up this
dangerous material I'm wondering if it
also has something to do with that but
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the episode or
your worst moment depending on how you
think about it I think for most people
it's probably going to be the death of
Shiva because she's such a cool
character and it's such a bummer for her
to go this early in the season but if
she's gonna go I am happy that they gave
her the comic-book death but like I said
earlier probably the best episode of the
season if they can continue doing
episodes like this I feel like they can
turn things around because people seem
relatively disappointed with the season
so far just after the last couple of
episodes so hopefully they'll turn a
corner and will seem better at character
work in action like this but we got till
episode 8 for the mid-season finale but
in related news I'm doing special
Justice League premiere stuff tomorrow
you may have spotted the Punisher add
that they played during The Walking Dead
episode The Punisher is dropping this
Friday and the embargo is up so my
non-spoilery review of season 1 will
also post tomorrow but no spoilers it
was actually a really cool season so if
you really like Shane you really like
the punisher all the episodes will be
available on friday but there's a new
round of the walking dead giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment
this video congratulations to the winner
from the last video cast Cobb
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for all my other Walking Dead videos and
you can click here for my Thor Ragnarok
deleted scenes in alternate post credits
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight